the couple will represent the next award
are married and that may not last much
longer because he just directed his
first picture and she is not in it
Richard Benjamin and Paula Prentiss
thank you we have the privilege of
announcing the documentary film awards
not the nominees for documentary short
subjects are America in transition
ob Benz producer Nigel noble producing
journey for survival pick young
producing see what I say Linda Chapman
Pam LeBlanc
and Freddy Stevens producers urge to
build Roland Holloway and John Hoover
producers the winner is closed harmony
but when the limousine pulled up in
front of the theater my son said you
mean I have to get out in front of all
those people I feel exactly the same way
I would like to thank the Academy for
this honor I also would like to thank
the children of Brooklyn friends school
the senior citizens of the council
center for senior citizens in in
Brooklyn and a dynamic music teacher who
brought these two groups together
Arlene Simmons like my crew came Van
Sickle
KITT Whitmore Steve curbs and Tom Holton
Maggie Travis wonderful wonderful people
who devoted themselves to the film and
Joan Morris who did a tremendous job
editing the film in China now the
American film industry needs her back
and I would like to thank Ruth Kalkstein
and Lee Berry for their support I would
like to thank the National Council of
Jewish women Brooklyn section who made
this film possible my wife Jane for
suggesting the idea and my cheering
section in the balcony David Benjamin
and Zachary thank you very much
dominating adult achievement and
documentary features are against wind
and tie the Cuban Odyssey - Susan Bauman
Palma tenkan and Jim burrows Patricia's
Brooklyn Bridge
Ken Burns producer eight minutes to
midnight the portrait of Helen Caldicott
Mary Benjamin Suzanne Simpson and Boyd
Estes producers El Salvador another
Vietnam Glen Silber and Tata vasconcelos
producers genocide Arnold Schwarzenegger
a by Marvin hire producers the winner is
genocide
the order trustee is the same reasons
will center and its dean rabbi marvin
hire to give me the opportunity of
making this film to Elizabeth Taylor and
Orson Welles for their wonderful
innovation mr. simon wiesenthal for his
marvelous help and advice during the
production Elmer Bernstein for wonderful
score Martin Gilbert there are so many
people including my wife is older who
did research with me on the film Peter
Schilling furred Roy Watts Bob Jenkins I
just can't remember anymore but there
was so many people I thank you very much
I just want to add my special thanks to
the board of trustees of the Simon
Wiesenthal Center of eeschema University
of Los Angeles for making this film
possible and for Simon Wiesenthal who
stood alone all these years so that the
world would not forget this film is
dedicated to the memory of the villagers
they have no graves but their memory
will live to the end of time thank you